they are amazing stories but obviously
they're not you're not the only person
in the book did you contact other people
like for Gerry Hannibal did you ring her
and say is it okay if I put that story
about no yeah yeah yeah yeah she doesn't
she just no no you were you were dating
at the time what we were dating we were
friends and you know and to have this
flat in Notting Hill and the window was
it was quite public it was quite a
public flat and I'd be watching the TV
and the boss had pull up and it'd be the
top deck and they'd just be like
watching Robbie Williams watch the
television every 20 minutes and that
particular evening Jerry was around at
the flat and I don't know how but 20 to
25 paparazzi were outside and they were
letting the flash lights go off like
this trying to get us to come to the
window and I thought I'm gonna phone the
police and see what my rights are I
don't want to bother the police but I'd
like to know because this is weird and
the policeman came around I said I'm
really sorry to get you around me I
don't want to be a hindrance but I've
got all of these paparazzi and I just
want to know what my rights are and the
policeman goes go stop you and I said oh
yeah and he said when you start out in
your career that's when you want the
press isn't it well then when the press
wants something from you you don't like
that do you know
Leesville in my house and the geri
halliwell hiding in the cupboard right
now I've just got to get him out because
I don't want to be told off yeah thanks
mate thanks for coming around you're
right I'm sorry DAF the cap off you went
I'm like Jerry we can't do anything
about the paparazzi and we we should get
out of here
and I think genius idea to put her in a
whole doll
literally put her in this duffel bag
over my shoulder the paparazzi are all
taking pictures am i hi guys
she had a car and I put her in the boot
of a car which is funny so when we got
to the service station and I had a KFC I
could have let her out
you know nature called
i-i-i-i've that chicken yeah that was
the moment Geri Halliwell was putting a
whole doll in my house it's in the book
you
[Music]